MODERATOR: So if you have a
live question, that's the mic.
The floor is open.
So the first question
from Eric in Portland,
how does Polymer stack up
with other Web Component
implementations in
terms of performance?
[INAUDIBLE]
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So
I can take that.
My name is almost
Alex Komoroske.
I didn't present tonight.
I'm a product manager
working on Polymer and Blink.
So one of the important things
to think about with Polymer
is this is a framework
for the future.
This is a library
And so as browsers ship
these web component standards
natively, it will just
automatically speed up.
So Chrome has many of
the pieces shipping,
and we hope that HTMLImports
will make into M36.
And so our goal in
browsers that don't
get support the Web
Components' emerging standards
is to have performance
that's comparable to what
you would get in
frameworks today.
But once browsers ship these
native implementations,
it just gets much, much faster.
MALE SPEAKER 1:
Yeah, so performance
is a really complicated topic.
So it's actually a
little bit difficult,
and Web Components
is a very broad term.
So the question's a little
bit difficult to answer.
But Polymer actually
isn't an implementation
of Web Components.
Web Components is a native
feature that Polymer is using.
And that native feature,
because it's in the browser,
should, long term,
be a better bet.
MALE SPEAKER 2: So
I'll reiterate that
with xtag that's maybe an
implementation of a library
to make Web Components
even easier to use.
One awesome thing about
that is that we all
use the same polyfills.
So the 80% of that
code is the same.
So the performance
characteristics
you'll see in xtag
or Polymer are
going to be very, very alike.
And I think that's something
that, when they get down
to native, and most of
the library is native,
and it's just that layer
that they talked about,
you're not going to
see much difference.
MODERATOR: OK.
Great.
So again, if you have a
question in the audience,
just line up at
the mic and ask it.
I'll take another
moderator question.
So Jonathan Garby, a heavy
WebPlatform Docs contributor,
is asking one of the highest
voted questions, can Polymer
and the work in
progress standards
is based on perform with
a small enough difference
in rendering compared to
server generated pages?
Again, performance.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Let me take
a stab at this one, as well.
So the way I think of it
is that the WebPlatform
is a series of tools.
It's a series of APIs and
capabilities that you can use.
What Web Components
does is it adds
a number of tools on the end.
But what I've found
personal and other people
as they explore
using Web Components
and imagining this future
is that a lot of the best
practices we have found have
turned out to be local maxima.
So server side
rendering is an example
where it's just received
wisdom at this point
that you're going to need
to do server side rendering
to get really fast
initial load performance.
Actually, a number
of folks internally
have explored Web
Components and the future
of [INAUDIBLE]
components very in depth
have found that, actually, it
might be the answer that-- what
you should do is cache your
component definitions very
heavily client side and
pass down something that
has just semantic looking
markup, inflates locally.
So I think what's exciting
about all this stuff is
the addition of a few
more tools on the end
sometimes upsets a lot of these
best practices we've found
and allows us to find a much
better place somewhere else.
MALE SPEAKER 3: Also, too,
the ability with HTMLImports
is we can actually change the
way we deliver applications.
So you can think
about an app that
has the bare bones minimum.
You deliver that to the user
in a second or something.
That is this thing that
need to see right away.
And then using Imports,
you can effectively
offload a lot of the rest of the
app and load things on demand.
So it does change the
way we structure apps.
The second part to this is
there's nothing stopping you
from just having a server that
outputs a bunch of custom HTML
markup.
If you had a server that output,
like, a megabyte of HTML,
you're going to have a problem.
That's going to be slow.
Nothing changes in the
world of custom elements.
The difference is
that what happens
is things get activated
on the client side.
It's ultimately a
client side technology.
MODERATOR: Again, questions?
Just hit the mic.
Does Polymer HTMLImports
implementation
load imported HTML files
asynchronously like AMDjs?
Just got this one.
MALE SPEAKER 1: So AMD
modules and HTMLImports,
which is really what
the question is about,
are different things.
One is about JavaScript,
and I don't actually
know too much about it.
And then there's HTMLImports,
which is actually HTML.
That said, the underlying
technology of HTMLImports
has async attribute.
If you go that route,
things become very difficult
very quickly, but it's
totally an option.
MALE SPEAKER 2: One
bit of information
I do have with this, in speaking
with Dave Herman at Mozilla,
which I did frequently,
is that we're actually
talking about having a module
tag, potentially, inside
of HTMLImports that
will allow you--
it already has
its own DAC, so it
does do some
dependency resolution.
But the module
tag will allow you
to do things that are
very, very AMD-esque.
Because, as you know,
modules coming in ES 6
are essentially a
form of AMD, provide
a lot of the same features, so
that's coming in HTMLImports.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So next
question was similar.
Does it play well
with AMD modules?
I think it's kind
of covered, but--
MALE SPEAKER 3: I just want to
say, too, AMD and JavaScript
modules is a technology
that loads JavaScript.
With Imports, you can load
CSS, HTML, everything.
It's a different way
to deliver dependencies
in the world of Web Components.
So it's fundamentally a
different thing to think about,
but as Daniel said,
there's explorations
of how to combine
these two technologies.
I think when we have more
capabilities in JavaScript,
like modules and classes and
all this cool stuff that we're
totally promised in ES 6 and
7 and 8 and 9 and 10, 11,
we'll eventually be able to
combine a lot of the stuff.
And everything is actually--
at the lowest levels--
has been thought about.
I promise you.
People are actually
exploring different ways
to-- what does implementing
ES 6 classes look
like in the world
of custom elements?
That is something that
started from day one
and has been going on.
The conversations are there.
MODERATOR: Cool.
All right.
Let's take an audience question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Philip.
I have a question.
So-- microphone beeping.
OK.
I think we need
to pull this here.
Is that better?
I think I have to
talk really quietly.
MODERATOR: We'll
repeat the question.
AUDIENCE: How does a
library like Polymer--
how does it interact with
existing model view controller
frameworks?
If I'm already using
Backbone or Angular,
how can I use Web Components?
Because it seems to do a lot
of things that those frameworks
do now.
I actually felt a bit weird
when you used that tag
to pull in data from a
server because usually you
would do that through a model.
How do you see that
working in the future?
MODERATOR: Can you maybe
repeat the question?
How does it work with
other client libraries?
Backbone and so on.
MALE SPEAKER 3: You
covered this, right?
MALE SPEAKER 1:
I'm having trouble.
OK.
I'm getting all the hard ones.
So, like I said,
Polymer integrates
with existing technologies
relatively well
if they're just
using the elements.
And where else should
I go with that?
MAKE SPEAKER 4: Yeah.
So one thing to point out
is that Polymer elements
and these MVC
frameworks, they're
not mutually exclusive
by any means.
They do work together.
And there's lots
of different ways
that you can build
your application.
So we're not trying to say,
hey, always use Core AJAX.
It's just a thing
that we created.
We think it's really awesome.
We think it's a nice
way to work with AJAX.
But it's up to you
guys how you want
to actually build
your applications.
So if you want to leverage
it, by all means, please do.
But there's lots of ways
to skin that cat, I think.
MODERATOR: Let's take
another audience question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I have two quick questions.
So the first one-- there's
a bunch of imports up there,
and I think everyone's
thinking the same thing.
It's a bunch of HTTP requests.
What is the current
state of bundling
these all together so you
can get it on to one HTTP
request while
preserving encapsulation
and all that stuff?
The second question is, there
was a great demo, an xtag demo,
of an auto sizing
text area element.
Can that currently be
submitted with a form?
Like the value attribute
of that element,
does the native form browser
element know to extract that?
Like, you can extend
a native element,
but does it go the other way
where you can-- because it's
being extended from a text
area, does the form element
know to get the value
when submitting the form?
MALE SPEAKER 2: So, yeah.
In xtag we support-- there's
actually two definitions.
I don't know if we went over
this is any of the talks.
When you use an element that
inherits from a native element,
there's the is equals
syntax, the is attribute.
So if you had a text
area, you could say,
text area is your tag and
then is equal super text area.
In that case, you would be
able to use the same prototype,
and, inherently, a value
from an input or something
like that would actually
post to the form it's in.
So that's all baked in.
And some people even like to
use their own text area input
inside of an actual
custom element name.
So either way, you get that.
MALE SPEAKER 1: So back
to the first question
on how to optimize for a
limited number of requests.
So a few things.
One, this is one of those
classic cases where Polymer
is not taking away any
of your current toys.
So it just works like
everything else does.
You can actually pass it
through those parsers.
That said, we also have a tool
called Vulcanizer, which we're
writing, which is out there
today and has documentation
specifically that knows how
to deal with Polymer elements
and can combine them into a
single CSS file, single JS
file, and single HTML file, and
can optionally pull out the JS
into an external file
for CSP environments.
So we're working on the
tooling, but it shouldn't really
break the current tools anyway.
MALE SPEAKER 3: I just
want to reiterate.
This is a really
important point.
Like the web development
best practices
don't change in the
world of Web Components.
So what you didn't see
tonight was the ability to--
instead of having your script
tag in line in your element,
you can totally reference
an external script.
Instead of having
your style sheets
in line in a style
tag in your element,
you can totally
reference a style sheet.
So this is great because
you can use things
like minifiers, grunt tasks.
You can write your elements in
CoffeeScript, for all we care.
It's about you and
your productivity,
and it doesn't really change
the way we develop it.
Kind of just changes the way
you think about building apps.
MODERATOR: So I'm going
to take a quick lightning
question here.
Are there plans to support
IE8 9, 10 Android browser?
Quick answer?
MALE SPEAKER 1: Yep.
So IE 10 is supported.
So Polymer-- we didn't
do this particularly
well in the presentations,
but the last two
versions of every major
browser are supported.
so IE 8 and IE 9 are
not included in that.
And then the other exception
is the Android browser,
which is also not
included in that.
So that's a relatively
straightforward one.
MALE SPEAKER 2: So
one note on that
is IE actually had a hook
that would-- when I was doing
the polyfill, we
had split polyfill--
that's when they agreed to
merge and use the same one.
You would be able to
do it if they hadn't
have got rid of HTC files
and CSS behaviors in IE8.
Oddly enough, it's like this
skip ground where it's up to 7,
they skip it in 8, and then 9
has all these affordances that
are standard web.
So it's kind of not possible.
MODERATOR: All right.
So, audience question.
AUDIENCE: So going
back to performance,
I just see that
people put together
a bunch of components
on the page
because it's nice and easy.
And maybe you have 20
of them, and they all
include 20 different
copies of jQuery,
and they're all maybe
different versions
of jQuery, all on
that same page.
So how do we deal with that?
MALE SPEAKER 1: So HTMLImports
have a de-duping future.
It's currently based
off of the absolute URL.
So if you have
different versions,
or they come from
different CDNs,
that's going to be a problem.
There's already a bunch
of work in the spec
to try and address
that, as well,
and do it relatively quickly.
That said, there's
nothing that prevents you
from doing that
today on the web.
So there are certain-- making
something very, very easy
allows you also make
mistakes very, very easily,
and I'll totally admit to that.
But for the most part, it's not
it's not an additional problem.
That said, the ability
of HTMLImports to de-dupe
is pretty awesome.
If we can get it to do
it in other aspects,
that would be great, too.
And if you're including,
like, five versions of jQuery
on your page, you're
probably in trouble, anyway.
MODERATOR: Cool.
Take a quick question here.
Will AngularJS and Polymer
merge in the future?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: OK.
I'll take that one.
So I think Angular is
a great example of one
of the frameworks
of today that's
done an amazing job of
building a very, very
effective framework.
One thing that's
important to remember--
and I think Matt hit
on this in his talk--
is that, with Web
Components, the world
is a very different place.
So things that were created
before the Web Components
revolution may have
to rethink some
of things in this new world.
So Polymer is a
great example where
it's been born in this new
world, assuming Web Components
and being able to
design for that.
I think it's really exciting
to watch the Angular team
talk about using
things like Shadow
DOM and other aspects
of Web Components.
And I imagine that, over time,
a number of different frameworks
will start embracing this
Web Components revolution.
And Ember, as well,
as Daniel points out.
MODERATOR: OK.
We'll take an audience question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for doing this.
What kind of testing
strategy would you recommend?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So
we have actually
the engineer who's built
out testing structure here,
Daniel, who's one of
the Polymer engineers.
DANIEL: I had my
backpack on, ready to go.
So I'm Daniel.
I work on the Polymer team.
How we've been testing
our elements so far
is we've been using
Mocha and Chai
and just doing regular tester
and development style tests.
We find that, for the
most part, what we
write is a UI for our elements.
And you can write tests
for, like, [INAUDIBLE] style
and see that your elements
got the styling correctly,
but we really don't
have a good story for,
like, oh, I changed this
one little thing here.
How different is
it on the screen?
We really maybe need
some sort of-- it
would be great if we had
some sort of trimmings
on the platform that
compared screenshots,
perhaps, of elements
as we built on.
But, so far, it's just
your standard test.
Oh, yeah.
To be able to actually test
some elements in a real browser
environment, a
member of our team
wrote a plugin to Mocha
that spins up iframes
so we can run our tests,
launch browsers with Karma,
and put our elements
in pages, make sure
that they are--
individually, they
run without colliding
with each other
by putting them in iframes.
And it's a little
slow because iframes
aren't super quick to spin up,
but we can run our full test
suite in about five minutes.
And it's not the
end of the world.
And it would be
really great if we
had more printers
in the platform
for all the Blink
engineers watching.
MALE SPEAKER 2: So
some other person
wrote this, like a back
end guy, so I can't really
speak to the detail,
but I know we
have tests in xtags that
do Slammer and WebDriver
over Sauce Labs and do
actually take a screen shot.
I don't know how
extensible that is,
so if you check the repository,
maybe it works really easily.
Maybe it doesn't.
I can't speak to that.
But it is one way that
we try to do GUI testing.
MODERATOR: All right.
So we've got three
final audience questions
if they can be short and sweet.
AUDIENCE: How do you handle
testing of accessibility
for Web Components?
MODERATOR: Don't go anywhere.
DANIEL: So I do mostly
accessibility testing
as it is right now.
I also work with some
members of the Chrome team
who are in the accessibility
working groups,
like the ARIA spec and the
platform something something--
the one that talks
to screen readers
and those people who
implement screen readers.
So the good news is that,
even with a Shadow DOM
scoping mechanism, screen
readers general support that.
The ARIA spec allows
for-- actually,
if you were to open Chrome
and turn on the flag that
says show user [INAUDIBLE]
Shadow DOMs, which shows you
how native elements are
built, if you open up,
like, an input
for date time, you
can see that all of the
native widgets in Chrome
actually use accessibility
features of ARIA. so you can
see that they are, like,
role for a calendar,
and they say what
their controls are.
So that's already working today.
And then when we test-- a very
nice member of the Chrome team
just finished wrapping up the
Accessibility Developer toolkit
extension for Chrome.
So you can run audits
on your elements that
run against the full
ARIA test suite.
So we've just started using
that and the elements we
work on-- I go
through a manual pass
right now of just making sure
they've got the proper roles
and they look good
in a screen reader.
But as soon as everybody
can start implementing that.
MODERATOR: OK.
Final two quick questions
and quick answers.
AUDIENCE: Question
will be quick.
I don't know about the answer.
This is more of a
philosophic question.
I know it's early days for
Polymer and especially Web
Components.
Where do you guys,
collectively or individually,
see for Web Components going
in terms of standardization
and specifically
for editorializing
in terms of central
repository, or kind of
let community decide what's
going to be the ultimate way
to find things
and detect things?
Is the more the Ruby model
that's, like, wild, wild west,
or the Python sort of everything
comes from CPAN kind of--
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I think
there's two parts to that.
On the standardization
side for the specs
for the Web Components platform
APIs like custom elements
and Shadow DOM, those
have been going on in W3C
for a number of years.
I think they're going very well.
On the other front,
for the community
of how people talk
about Web Components,
I was really encouraged
by the works I know
and others have been
doing on Web Components
at [INAUDIBLE], in particular.
I think that's a
really good first step.
It's a good place for component
authors and framework authors
to share their best
practices, to try
to come to terms on exactly
how they work so that they
can be used interoperably.
And I imagine that
something like that
could grow over time to be a
place that developers could
go to find Web
Components, as well.
I think Jan, as well, has
shown with what he showed off
that there'll be a number
of different places
to find these things.
I think that will be really
healthy for the ecosystem.
MALE SPEAKER 2: So I've
actually been talking with Addy.
I don't know if
you know the guy.
Works at Google.
Does lots of web
development stuff.
We talked with folks from
Opera in a meeting a little
while ago about a-- every
couple weeks, we have a meeting.
And this came up.
And we're actually trying to
develop a way that you can do,
like, crowd source code reviews
of elements and get them in one
central repository
on the .org site.
And that allows you to
do, like, JS Manners
sort of checks as a community.
So that could be good.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So I think
it's really encouraging
how far we've already
come, even though it's
a very fledgling ecosystem.
So I think that's a good
sign for the future.
MODERATOR: All right.
The final question
of the evening
is by one of the authors of
this fine book, John Bennett.
AUDIENCE: So my question is
about attributes as components.
For example, it would
be nice to have--
if you're doing
internationalization-- have
a translate attribute you
can put on any web component,
and it's not just
a single component.
Is that something that's
possible with Web Components
or with any of the platforms,
like xtags or Polymer?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So you mean
custom attributes in general?
AUDIENCE: So as an
example, there's
a plugin for Angular
called Angular Get Text,
and you can just stick
a translate attribute
onto an element, and it
will translate it and do
a bunch of Get Text
magic under the hood.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I think this
exact question actually came up
on polymer-dev
today or yesterday.
And the answer that
somebody has given so far
enough-- I don't know if
it's a canonical one or not--
is that you could choose
to implement the behavior
on a base class and then inherit
from that for other things.
But the design of Web
Components as I understand it--
and I don't know all the
particulars well enough--
but you couldn't just
have a special attribute
that you mix into lots
of different elements.
MALE SPEAKER 2: So in
xtag, we have the mix ins
and the pseudos features would
allow for this sort of thing.
So you could say,
translate this attribute,
and then that reflects in data
or a mix in for translate.
It would still require--
you'd have to do some coding.
There's no thinking
around it right now.
It's possible.
MODERATOR: OK.
I think we're going
to have to close it.
Thanks for the great questions.